so let's start by setting the scene
so we will talk about content websites
and for that we need to clarify what the
content website is
so first off according by step needs
content like that's actually the thing
that people want to read
and on contact websites you usually have
little interaction like the reading the
content is the main service
and navigation happens
via links so when you go to a new page
you click on the menu somewhere
like it actually means there's a new
HTML file
or a new HTTP request
here are some examples of content
websites so maybe you have some
information like a company website or a
hobby website
you could have some documentation for
apis for libraries Frameworks for tools
maybe like a newspaper or like a Blog
or you can have like a shop even a shop
is mostly static like with some Dynamic
parts
and usually with for most websites you
have like a combination of all of these
so maybe you have a lot of information a
little bit of documentation maybe you
have a new section on your page and then
a simple uh shop integration
and technically they are sort of like
two ways to do it and one is like the
mpa style that is sort of like the
classical way of uh shipping HTML and
that's on the server you have a lot of
HTML sites HTML files and then you
organize them based on a folder
structure and then this folder structure
just gets served by the server
and this is a little bit different to
the spa style that's single page
application where you usually only have
like one HTML file and then
all the other parts are dynamically
loaded using JavaScript and you take the
the first index HTML is basically taking
over the full routing of the whole
website
and to sort of get this out of the way
like MPA versus spas
both can produce amazing sites so
there's no need to battle mpas are
usually a little bit easier to get right
especially when you look at the
performance characteristics because with
an MPA you can have a new chance
whenever you go to a new page like you
have a new chance of get the performance
correct so like if you have one page
that's like totally slow like other
pages are not affected at all whereas in
Spa depending on how it's implemented it
could have an effect
but Spas are like the king when it comes
to high interactivity so like if you
want to build something like figma
that's the only way
and also Spas can give you this app
feeling
that you saw like if you want to compete
with a native app like an nspa is the
way to go for now because there's uh
something in the world called the shared
element transition API and that will
hopefully also enable this smooth
transitions between multiple HTML files
even if they are separate requests
and let's start building it and we call
it like 90 style we will do it like
really old school
so we just make a new folder we put an
index.html file in there and it looks
something like this
so really
um
just some doctype and HTML
you put some body tag in there and in
the body you have the actual content and
in there we have a link that just goes
to a different HTML file
so then we create this HTML file as well
and we add then some Styles and
JavaScript as needed as much as we want
and this is our site and all we need to
do like to get this live is drop it
somewhere drop it on the server this is
like from netlify and all you need to do
is like take this folder put it up no
processing no anything and it will be a
live site that you can deploy and use
and this is basically how the web
started how the web worked from the
beginning
it has HTML that provides the basic
structure and on top of that you apply
CSS to enable you to yeah control the
presentation like in the formatting
and then you have like JavaScript and
JavaScript enables you to yeah do
different behaviors that are not baked
into HTML and the browser itself
and then we enter the era of components
so with components we could sort of like
start with the wish list what should
components do they should of course work
in the browser and ideally just the
source directly they should make
maintainability like really good
they should instantly render
there should be no side effects
especially with CSS and they should be
configurable
and let's start with HTML components
let's have this very simple example
where we have like a header and then
some buttons and the and the number and
we could say like that this part
this enclosure this could be seen as a
component
and it could look something like this
where you have these parts like the
these are the actual component and as
you can see they're like in two separate
places and it's a lot of things you need
to put into so I would consider them
more like conceptual components
because they are
you need to
do a lot of stuff yourself and they
usually start with having a reperative
where you just apply a class
and then you as a user you need to put
all the HTML yourself
and the same goes through for like
Styles in JavaScript if the component
needs it so some components might not
need uh JavaScript and you don't need to
put it
and here's like the CSS file for that
and as you can see like it there's sort
of like this convention that you need to
start with the actual component name
that you put which is like counter but
if you by accident put something else in
there you could have affected other
parts of your application
and the same goes for JavaScript like
the JavaScript runs in the global
context so you need to sort of like
first select your Dom node
that you want to like put the logic on
so how we're doing on our wish list
so the source Works in a browser that's
simple like it's just HTML JavaScript
and CSS maintainability is I think not
that great because if the HTML structure
changes you need to change it in a lot
of places we get instant rendering
because like CSS loading is like render
blocking
we do have side effects if you put the
wrong stuff in your CSS file then boohoo
and configurable I would say everyone
can basically do whatever in their HTML
so you can place everything but I would
not say that that's configurable
but let's compare this with a react
component so here we're just having
import of the the counter and we put it
in our app so it's like a single class
function tag whatever you want to use to
uh to create this counter
and that could be an example how it
could look like
and I'm here actually reusing the exact
same counter CSS so it could have the
same side effects as well so if you want
to like have scoping you probably want
to introduce something like a CSS and JS
to make this more scoped
so how we're doing on the wish list like
the source works not really because you
need to compile the jsx out you can do
this in the browser but then you need to
ship an extra runtime
maintainability is like way better you
have just this single tag that you need
to place in there
we don't get instant rendering
because you first need to like ship the
JavaScript before you can actually see
the component rendered
and no side effects you can enable it
but you need to like actually take
action to make it possible but it's
really configurable like you have a nice
API you can
yeah put props on it and that will be
your public API
and now let's compare it with our
components
so what components like we heard before
like the exact same as a browser tag so
it's the exact same API so that means
like we have attributes and properties
that go in and we have like slots that
can also go in and we have events that
go out
and as a user what you need to do in
order to use such a component you
basically just put the tag on HTML and
it's there and in order to make sure
that it's sort of like that the browser
knows what you should put in there you
need to load the code for it and that's
a single script act that you need to put
in there so like just two lines and you
get the same functionality
but now what will what is in this my
counter file like how do you define it
and you start by extending HTML element
and then you need to sort of connect the
actual tag name with your class
and that is with custom elements Define
and if we look at a little more into
detail what we will write in there
we see the first thing that's probably
unfamiliar is like attached shadow
and that means we're now creating the
shaladam that was explained already
multiple times but I will go really
quickly over it because I think this is
one of the core parts that we need to
know
so a shadow Dom
the thing is that the browser always had
it
like if we look at the video tag I think
it's the best example for a shadow Dom
it's always there it uses it it enables
really full CSS encapsulation like you
cannot Escape it and it separates the
Dom from into light and Shadows on
so here's like the video example so this
is basically I think you probably are
all familiar with this like you put a
video tag you put the source and this
will display the video for you with some
controls and it always felt a little bit
like magic like how can one tag do so
much
and the answer is like that it really is
more than just one tag you have here
this video tag and then we have our
source tag all the way but at the bottom
and then all this in between
this is the like the user agent chat
root and as you can see there is like a
lot of HTML that actually Powers the
internals of the video tag
and with Shadow Dom you can build this
you can use the same technology to make
your components and this offers the True
full CSS encapsulation
so I can have this example here so if I
have a style tag with an H1 and then an
H1 that is in the body and then I have a
diff and inside of this diff I have
another style that changes the
background
to different color and another H1
what will be the outcome
and if we sort of like Follow The
Logical top to bottom rule of CSS
basically H1 will get the hot pink color
and it will apply to all H1s
and now what we're doing as different so
let's say is like all we do we introduce
a shadow root here
so like we have the same diff but now
instead of like rendering the Dom into
the same main Dom we're rendering the
Dom into the shadow shadow root of this
diff
and now it changes because now the H1
selection
only applies to its own shadow Dom and
not the rest of the page
so now we finally have our shadow Dom
now we want to put something into our
shutter down and we do this with a
shadow root a pen child
and then we clone the template and
what's in this template
here it's just some sort of like text
that we want to put in there
and as we saw before like we can
actually now use very simple CSS
selectors in our HTML in our CSS to like
map to the to the HTML so it's like
enables you to make simpler smaller
components and like do not need to worry
about uh yeah side effects of CSS
and then we can go a step further and
like this is sort of like then the data
logic in the sense of that enables you
to like actually press the buttons uh
and update the actual HTML and then
finally we need to register it with the
actual Tech name
so with that we have a component that
works the same as all the other
components that we created today
and how we're doing like the source
works in the browser as is there's not
nothing you need to change it's I think
very maintainable because it's like a
yeah it's the same public apis all the
other Dom nodes have
we still don't have instant rendering
because you need to wait until it's uh
yeah until the JavaScript is loaded and
executed and with shutter down we get we
yeah we have no side effects because you
can put whatever you want in your CSS
and it will not affect outside of the
component and it's very configurable by
using the Dom apis
so why do we even use components
I think components are a very good
mental model at least for me personally
for me it's a very natural way of
thinking how I want to arrange
an application or how when I arrange a
page
it also enables us to encapsulate code
really well so we can keep all relevant
code in the same location and we call
subtested in the same location and
because there are no side effects like
we can make sure that they are in a good
State and we can maintain them
and with this it will also enable us to
like reuse code so we can actually make
a component that is used for other by
other people like it's and all they need
to know is about
the public API and that enables for
example things like an API that we can
do a complex API calls and we just need
to know the Dom basics
so our component is the Promised Land
and maybe
but there are consequences
because now what we basically did we
have components that render only on the
client
so that means the HTML that we ship
may be completely different to what the
browser actually renders
so that has implications for sale or
also like for rendering
and we have the HTML and the components
are completely separate so like the
initial HTML and the components are
completely separate which leads to
Infamous white page or white section
experience that we all don't like
so first the shipped HTML so here this
is what we ship actually as our request
as our response to our request so we
have our H1 and our my counter really
nice to write and really nice to ship
but the browser then actually render
something completely different it
creates a shadow root and it has more
content inside of it
and this can lead to this white page
section experience so when we start the
page like the rendered HTML directly we
see the H1 but our component is nowhere
to be seen
because the content of the component
only appears after JavaScript gets
downloaded and executed
so what did we do with components
basically we enabled us to make our life
easier but the user experience actually
got worse
so what we need to do is like we need to
fix it
and
the solution in this case is SSR
server-side rendering there's like this
huge debate about like is it on demand
server side rendering that only can run
in the cloud or on the server or can it
also run on the build but in our case we
don't care
All We Care is like we want to focus on
what the SSR output is so what is the
actual HTML that we will ship to our
users
and our goal is to like make sure that
the shipped HTML is as closely as
possible to the browse HTML that gets
actually executed
so how is this in react I think in react
like it's very nice because you
basically can't just render it it's
already fully declarative
and you have just HTML and your stylings
are sort of like Global so you can't
just ship it as is
for web components it's a little
complicated because what the hell is
this how can you have a shadow root and
send Shadow root with HTML and for that
we actually needed a new spec which is
called DSD declarative shutdown
and declarative Shadow Doom means you
can create a shadow route without
needing JavaScript
that's currently chromium only but
there's like a very small simple
polyfill available and it's very
straightforward because what it actually
does
in order to introduce a shadow root you
create a template with Shadow root open
and the content inside will then be
turned into a shadow route on parse time
so when you send the above HTML to the
browser the browser will while it parses
from top to bottom the HTML it will
automatically convert this template tag
into a shutter root and will attach the
Dom nodes to the shadow root instead of
the main Dom
so how can we make our component Now
using this so in this case we have our
example we can actually get rid of the
JavaScript completely
and then we add this template with the
shadow root inside of our shipped HTML
and with this shipped HTML now we have
basically this is now our new response
and what we get is this
so what we forgot is that in the shadow
Dom like we also need to include all of
our styles so now we have a shadow Dom
and we need to have the styling shipped
for each other Dom as well
and that is also true
if you have multiple components so each
component
or each Shadow root actually needs to
always have access to the full CSS and
the full HTML that it will contain if
you ship it with HTML
and for CSS that could be a lot
but there's no need to worry because the
transfer of HTML is usually compressed
and if you don't compress it then please
go now and enable it for your website
because it saves a lot of data anyways
and because it's compressed it will
reduce remove all the duplications so
that works perfectly fine and on top of
that browsers are really good at caching
CSS text
so even if you have a hundred components
that use the same style tag it will only
parse the first time and then for all
the other times it will like reuse the
same parse output instance to put into
the shutdown so like there's no
processing overhead if you ship it
multiple times so it's totally fine to
do this
so now the question is this is our
component on its full Glory
and how do we create this out of it
and I think for most of the part it's
okay especially the stylus you can just
take it as is and most of the HTML as
well but how do you do this like how do
you get the value and how you can how
can you make sure that you later are
able to update it
and for that there are sort of like two
ways you could start a full or fake
browser
or you could lay down some ground rules
and I can already hear some people
screaming like oh it's too slow oh it's
like too complex and honestly I fully
agree like having a full browser
rendering especially if you want to do
on-demand rendering will be just too
taxing and will take too much time
so we need to lay down some ground rules
and these rules are your HTML needs to
be fully declarative
so that means we can use something like
lit where we are actually putting the
the actual State inside of the HTML like
you used with jsx with this we can
enable server set rendering of this HTML
there can be no inter imperative
creation of dumb nodes so document
create element is no longer allowed if
you want to do suicide rendering if if
this Dom node needs to be part of this
server-side rendered output
you should not be use browser apis
instead of side effects so only start
using browser apis when you are actually
then hydrated on the client
and there are some life cycles that are
not called on the server side
and with this
we will be able to like rewrite the top
part
and then we have a script like or a
process in this case like I'm using lit
SSR that converts the top part into the
bottom part so we can write a nice
syntax and then it will be converted
into something that's performant to ship
so with this we get this output
and now when we try to click on it
nothing happens
so it's like oh yeah we removed the
actual JavaScript right
so no surprise
and that brings us into the error of
hydration and Islands
so on top of what we needed to do before
we need to do a little bit more
so I actually lied a little bit before
it's lit SSR outputs a little more so
instead of just shipping the HTML it
adds some metadata so we have all these
lit Parts in there as HTML commands and
they allow it to recognize which parts
are Dynamic and which parts which parts
are static and with that it can yeah get
control of like where the the value
actually goes
and if I have that I can then just load
the the actual class implementation as
soon as I want to and this will give me
back the interactivity that I wanted to
have
so now I can click again
and here sort of like a little site
conversion in the sense of like once you
load the JavaScript you get the full
interaction in the browser again and
that's one of the things I love about
web components is like you can just use
the browser default tools like open it
in the dev tools you can find the
component in the Dom like there is no
need to map it to something else you can
access the attributes and properties
directly in the console like by
referencing the Dom nodes with a dollar
zero and you can debug without Source
mobs directly so I think that's I really
like that that's experience
but now we want to build a site
and we have like an app header like a
menu then a filter and then like some
main content with some movie information
so we have like for this example like
seven components and we ship we want to
ship server-side rendered HTML and we
want to ship the JavaScript of those
seven components to make them
Interactive
so now we are shipping everything double
so we have basically this in our HTML
like we have a counter counter example
and then we have in the JavaScript we
have the exact same information again
why it's like a lot of double work
so
in a lot of cases we don't even need
that so in this our example like maybe
only yours are safe and maybe only the
star rating only those two things are
interactive like for all the other parts
we don't even need to have them
Interactive
so maybe just don't load or just don't
touch the rest like
but how like how can we how can the app
or how can we decide what to load and
what not
and that brings us to Progressive
hydration
and Progressive federations is a little
bit I think more of the main of
Frameworks
because now you're basically need to
manage the loading so that means you as
a user you're no longer allowed so to
say uh to load your components in the
way you want because you need to hand
this over to the framework because it
needs to then decide when to load it
based on some conditions and as far as I
know there are only two systems right
now like Ace Astro and rocket that
support this because like I'm doing a
lot for Rocket I will show the example
for this so what we're doing here like
we Define the component and we say like
this user safe that we want to make
interactive again we can assign the tag
name to the actual location and then we
also Supply the actual class name and
with that information rocket can decide
what to do so here we now have our body
and all of these components they're full
they will be fully server rendered
because there's no State whatsoever with
them
and only the user safe and also the
user's star rating those will be loaded
dynamically and we will use in this case
there are like multiple ways how can how
you can do loading but we will use
hydrate on visible so this component
will only load
when it becomes visible
so now to the we have a website it's
mostly static we are only shipping the
JavaScript for two components and the
rest never
never ends up on the client
we have great developer experience and
great user experience
so how we're doing on our comparison
slide so the source and I will now put
this together with reactant web
components together like if we use
server-side rendering we get the source
no longer really works in the browser
because we in the source with the actual
HTML is like a render Target so what we
write is not what we actually ship
but we have still great maintainability
we get this instant render because now
the initial HTML that you have directly
renders without any JavaScript we don't
need to wait for a JavaScript to display
the full page
um yeah the side effect and didn't
change
and both are still super configurable
so
that brings us a little bit into a look
Beyond
so islands and server side rendering
what does it mean or what could it mean
like you can go crazy with components
like everything visual should be a
component in my opinion if you can use
server-side rendering because if you
have only Styles there will be zero
runtime cost it will only be a cost on
the server and I think that's the
benefit of like having this component
size thinking is well worth like doing
this
so like take your cards take your icons
take your headlines whatever you choose
like make it a component and
only use stylus then you have zero
runtime cost
it enables you to have a simple
consistent developer experience for
every component so you don't need to
choose between what is interactive and
what is static
they could even be only server
components maybe components that grab
stuff from the file system like only
execute them on the on on the server and
then ship them just a static HTML and
never touch them again
and the benefit of like using web
components in this case is also like
even if you have no server-side
rendering capabilities with your system
or your service you can still just then
fall back to client rendering so it's
it's I think it's a good transition you
can do
and also you get the sale and
performance benefits uh doing this and
while we talk a little bit about
performance I want to showcase a little
how the react docs work
um so this is the page it looks mostly
static and it is and it starts off with
just two kilobytes of main thread
JavaScript so two kilobytes that is
purely like the hydration loader system
and then it hydrates component as needed
so as soon as you click uh on the on the
search for example then it loads the
search drop down and it loads more
JavaScript as needed because on and also
because these are web components these
are maybe like four or five kilobytes
that you then need to load it's like
really small
and on mobile for example like we have a
drawer and that will also then load as
needed
and the whole page works without any
JavaScript using declarative Shadow Dom
so this page I think uses like 15 or so
components but we ship basically Nothing
by default
and you can check it out at Rocket
monowepto Dev if you're curious and of
course because we're shipping almost
zero JavaScript like you get
very good scores performance everything
is perfect like it's interactive on in
1.1 seconds
on like a on a on a mobile phone on an
old mobile phone
and with that I want to sort of like end
it with a quote like do more with less I
think it's a crucial principle to learn
especially if you're going to be in
business in this rapidly changing world
so do less and let the sort of like on
the client do more on the server
thank you
[Applause]